hey hey guys welcome back to the channel
and as you can tell with the screen
overwatch has now a new update because
of the what is it the olympic games this
year so they added a bunch of skins
emotes victory poses everything in the
whole hero gallery basically but not it
wasn't for all the characters though
every character did get a voice line but
some characters got things others didn't
and i will be going over that in this
video toward the end of it but uh yeah
let's just get right into it guys i will
be showing you all the characters and
what everyone has so i won't be talking
for them for this video so right if you
guys did enjoy this video like it and
comment your opinion and tell me what
else you want to do next and other than
that guys subscribe and i will see you
all later peace
you really
look we can't eat I'm number one it met
what macaques I was hoping for a
challenge Green I choose ignore all
distractions the doc is are given a 10
I'll give what and be champions I'm not
don't much like losing overcome all
obstacles sub cake Ariel soup flat good
we are in this together it's in my
refrigerator are you one hundred percent
German power oops thought what what's
mine is mine that's what are you you are
a metal there's more where that came
from poke I don't miss cute petite
playtime's over rari not miss diet no
pain no gain I drooping weird they are
always strive for improvement
and that guy's was all of the stuff that
was in the new update just once again
guys like to say thank you for watching
the video like if you enjoyed come in
your opinion and subscribe so you can
see these new videos when they come out
and as I said before guys have a good
day in peace